you know Americans elected the outsider
businessman president why to borrow a
phrase from the man himself what do we
have to lose the economy was in the tank
our kids were living in the basement
because they couldn't find a job
factories were closing down jobs and
manufacturing were being shipped
overseas and in trade China was sucking
us dry the Obama folks called it a
healthy economy but there was barely a
pulse 1% annual GDP growth was the new
normal for these bozos and President
Obama even warned that Donald Trump's
election would result in economic
disaster for all Americans because some
of those jobs of the past are just not
going to come back and when somebody
says like the person you just mentioned
who I'm not going to advertise for that
he's going to bring all these jobs back
well how exactly are you going to do
that what are you going to do there's
there's no answer to it he just says
well I'm gonna I'm gonna negotiate a
better deal well hot what how exactly
are you going to negotiate that what
magic wand do you have and usually the
answer is he doesn't have an answer if I
want you to tell your friends you don't
let a friend vote Trump
[Applause]
so here's the deal he can't escape the
math now you know math can be kind of
inconvenient if it doesn't add up the
way you want it to and economists left
right in the middle all say the same
thing that Trump's policies would throw
us into a recession the last thing we
need he would undermine the growth that
we've had since the Great Recession in
the event Donald wins I have no doubt in
my mind the the market tanks this tax
plan in combination with his refusal to
reform entitlements and to honestly
address spending would balloon the
deficit and the national debt so even
though Donald Trump has offered very few
specific economic plans what little he
has said is enough to know that he would
be very bad for American workers and for
American families
and then there was Paul Krugman a Nobel
Prize winning economist writing for the
New York Times
let me say that again he's a Nobel
prize-winning economy and here's what he
said the stock market will plummet and
never recover from the election of
Donald Trump so we are very probably
looking at a global recession with no
end in sight you know some are so
blinded by their hatred of Donald Trump
that they forget decades of training in
their own field and as America surges
forward with more jobs than people to
fill them with african-american and
Hispanic unemployment the lowest in
history with millions coming off of food
stamps because they want to work the
left
well they rant and protest and create
chaos they throw people out of
restaurants and off television shows
they even go to church and say that God
sent them to destroy Donald Trump the
left doesn't care about our economic
success all they want to do is make
noise but it's nothing more than
background noise white noise the truth
nobody's paying attention to them Donald
Trump's
numbers continue to increase his
popularity just keeps going up and after
he met with Putin and was accused of
everything from collusion to treason an
offense by the way punishable by death
his numbers continue to go up when are
they gonna realize that they're yelling
and screaming is nothing but a
distraction
nobody cares we care about food on the
table paying the rent the mortgage
paying for kids clothing for school but
no they want to talk about [ __ ] and
porn stars or about a lawyer who they're
squeezing so tight he'll confess to
sinking the Titanic and yet despite a
media focused on a whack-a-mole
trump brush a collusion nonsense and the
haters continuing to hate the outsider
president has thundered forward with his
America first agenda and with a
kryptonite proof aura of invincibility
the forty-fifth outsider president often
working without the support of his own
party has produced a gdp that no one
thought possible 4.1 percent and we are
on track to hit the highest average
growth rate in over 13 years what do you
got to say to that Barak Hillary and all
you geniuses were flying folks this is
the America Donald Trump had in mind
when he asked us what do you have to
lose and that's my open